y agradecer a los 30.000 estadounidenses
que vinieron aquí para ayudarnos en
nuestro momento de necesidad su amor nos
dio la posibilidad de continuar pasamos
por el infierno pero hemos aprendido
mucho sabemos que nuestros problemas van
más allá del virus del virus
este es el síntoma no la enfermedad
nuestra nación está en crisis y en
muchas maneras el quid es solamente una
metáfora un virus que ataca cuando el
cuerpo está débil cuando no puede
defenderse en estos últimos años las
políticas de eeuu han sido débiles ha
habido un sentimiento de latino anti
inmigrante ha habido racismo en
charlottesville con el eco kux klan ni
siquiera quiso esconderse y en minnesota
donde se acabó la vida del señor floyd
solamente un cuerpo fuerte puede luchar
contra un virus
las divisiones de eeuu nos debilitan
donald chop no creo esta división
inicial la división creo a trump es
solamente la empeoró nuestra fortaleza
se ejerce a través del gobierno es
nuestro sistema inmune y en este momento
nuestro gobierno es incompetente no
podía luchar contra el virus de hecho ni
siquiera lo vio venir el virus europeo
llegó al noreste mientras la casa blanca
a un estado hablando de china el virus
había estado atacando nos durante meses
antes de que siquiera se dieran cuenta
que estaba aquí vimos el fracaso de un
gobierno que trató de negar este virus
que trató de ignorarlo y después trató
de politizarlo
el gobierno fallido que vio como esta
como nueva york fue víctima de esta
negligencia y nosotros aprendimos así
que hoy seis meses después de haber
comenzado la nación aún no está
preparada y ahora nos enfrentamos a una
segunda amenaza pero esta vez no de otra
naturaleza esta es una amenaza hecha por
el hombre hecha por nuestra propia
negligencia ahora vemos al virus
expandiéndose por el país de un estado
al otro hoy
estamos por detrás del mundo en la lucha
contra el cobe tenemos más de 5 millones
de cascos y hemos aprendido una lección
crítica que tan vulnerables somos cuando
estamos divididos y cuántas vidas pueden
perderse cuando nuestro gobierno es
incompetente pero hemos aprendido otras
cosas vimos lo negativo pero también lo
positivo nosotros probamos que nuestra
manera funcionó y tuvo éxito que podemos
levantarnos entre la educación que
podemos poner de lado las diferencias y
encontrar un terreno común el gobierno
puede decir la verdad y construir
confianza podemos juzgar por el contento
por el contenido del carácter y no el
color de la piel que podemos trabajar
juntos y forjar comunidades y un
gobierno competente que por supuesto
vamos a aportar máscaras porque somos
inteligentes y porque me importas y
porque yo te importa por supuesto que
vamos a distanciarnos socialmente porque
quedarnos lejos muestra que tan cerca
nos estamos realmente si vamos a
establecer
y rastrear y el rastreo porque somos
estadounidenses ganamos guerras y somos
el mejor país del mundo y a pesar del
dolor en las lágrimas nuestra manera
funcionó y fue hermoso mostramos que
estos ángeles son fuertes que
respondimos al llamado vimos que incluso
al final del día incluso si fue un día
largo el amor gana al final los ojos de
eeuu se han abierto y hemos visto aquí
la verdad de que el gobierno importa y
el liderazgo importa y determina si
triunfamos o si morimos o vivimos
necesitamos un líder que sea tan bueno
como nuestra gente un líder que haga un
llamado a lo mejor dentro de nosotros no
lo peor un líder que pueda unirnos no
dividirnos un líder que pueda
y levantarnos yo conozco a esa persona
he trabajado con ese hombre he visto su
talento he visto su fortaleza he visto
su dolor he visto su corazón ese hombre
es joe biden es lo que yo llamo un grupo
estadounidense rudo la mejor manera
un rudo inteligente una persona que une
que es disciplinada y que es amorosa el
poder restaurar el alma de eeuu y eso es
exactamente lo que nuestro país necesita
ahora gracias